this right here is a screenshot of the
line and angle proofs exercise on Khan
Academy and I thought we would use this
to really just get some practice with a
line and angle proofs and what's neat
about this this even uses translations
and transformations as ways to actually
prove things so let's look at what
they're telling us so it says line a B
and line de are parallel lines
all right perform a translation that
proves corresponding angles are always
equal and select the option which
explains the proof all right so let's
see what they have down here so they say
perform a translation performer that
proves corresponding angles are always
equal and then select the option that
that explains the proof so they've
picked two corresponding angles here and
so you see this is kind of the bottom
left angle this Phi and then you have
theta right here is a bottom-left angle
down here so these are corresponding
angles line F B is a transversal and
they already told us that line a B and
what do they call it do they call it de
and line de are indeed parallel lines so
we want to prove that these two things
that these two things that the measure
of these two angles are equal so there's
many ways that you can do this geometric
geometrically and we do that in many
Khan Academy videos but this one they
offer us the option of translating of
doing a translation so let's see what
that is so I press the translate button
and when I move this around notice it
essentially translates this these four
points which has the effect of
translating this entire intersection
here so if we take so this point that
where my where my mouse is right now
that is the point D and I'm translating
it around if I move that over to B what
it shows is because under a translation
the angle measures shouldn't change so
when I did that this this angle so
what's down here theta is the measure of
angle C D F and so when you move it over
here this right over here should be the
same this angles measure is the same as
C D F I've just trans
it and when you move it over here you
see look that's the same exact measure
as Phi so this is one way to think but I
just I just took I just
translated the point D to B and then it
really just translated angle C D F over
angle a B D so to show that these have
the same measure or at least to feel
good about the idea of them having the
same measure so let's see which choices
describe that so let me having trouble
operating my mouth all right
the translation mapping the translation
mapping point F to point D so point F to
point D point F to point D we did map
point F to point D so this is already
looking suspect produces a new line
which is a bisector of segment D be a
new line which is a segment a bisector
of segment BD okay this this doesn't
seem anything like what I just did so
I'm just going to move on to the next
one since the image of a line under
translation is parallel to the original
line that's true the translation that
map's point D to point B that's what I
did right over your maps angle C D F to
a BD and that's what I did I mapped
angle C D F to angle abd that's exactly
what I did what I did right over there
so this is two abd translations preserve
angle measures so theta is equal to Phi
yeah that one looks pretty good the
translation that Maps Point D to e I
didn't do that I didn't I didn't take I
didn't take point D and move it over to
e like that that didn't really help me
that would let's just keep reading it
just to make sure produces a
parallelogram that actually is true if I
if I translate point D to point a it
does I have this parrot this this
parallelogram get constructed but it
really doesn't help us establishing that
Phi is equal to theta so that one I also
don't feel good about so and it's good
because we felt good about the middle
choice let's do one more of these so
they are telling us that lie that line a
OB
a ob and they could have just they could
have just said line a B but I guess they
wanted to put the O in there to show
that point o is on that line that a OB
are collinear and C OD is our straight
lines all right fair enough
which of these statements prove vertical
angles are always equal so vertical
angles would be the angles on the
opposite sides of an intersection so in
order to prove that vertical so for
example angle AOC and angle DOB are
vertical angles and if we wanted to
prove that they are that they are equal
we would say well their measures are
going to be equal so theta should be
equal to Phi so let's see which of these
statements actually does that so this
one says segment o a is congruent to OD
o a is congruent to OD we don't know
that we don't they never even told us
that so we know this is I don't even
have to read the rest of it this is
already saying I don't know how far de
is away from oh I don't know if it's the
same distance as a is from O so we can
just rule this first choice out I can
just stop reading this started with a
statement that we don't know based on
the information they gave us so let's
look at the second choice if Rayo a and
Rhea OC are each rotated 180 degrees
about point O they must map to OB and OD
respectively if two rays are rotated by
the same amount the angle between them
will not change so Phi must be equal to
theta so this is interesting so let's
let's just let's just slow down and
think about what they're saying if Ray
Oh a and OCR each rotated 180 degrees so
if you take ray o a this ray right over
here if you rotate it 180 degrees it's
going to go all the way around and point
in the other direction it's going to
become ray it's going to it's going to
map to ray OB so I definitely believe
that Oh a is going to map to ray OB and
OC r AOC if you rotate 180 degrees is
going to map to Ray o D and so this
first statement is true if Ray o a and O
and Rhea OC are each rotated 180 degrees
about point O they must map to Ray OB
and OD respectively and when people say
respectively they're saying in the same
order that Oh a that rayo a maps to Ray
OB and that Ray OC maps to Ray Oh Dee
and we saw that Ray Oh a maps if you've
rotated all the way around 180 degrees
it'll map to OB and OC if you rotate 180
degrees will map to OD so I'm feeling
good about that first sentence if two
rays are rotated by the same amount the
angle between them will not change yeah
I could I yeah especially if they are if
they are if they are rotated around yeah
I'll go with that if two rays are
rotated by the same amount the angle
between them not change so if we rotate
both of these Ray's by 180 degrees then
we've essentially mapped to OB and OD or
another way to think about this angle
angle AOC is going to map to angle DB OD
and so that the the measure of those
angles are going to be the same so Phi
must be equal to theta so actually like
this second statement a lot so let's see
this last statement rotations rotations
preserve lengths and angles a B is
congruent to CD actually we don't know
whether segment we don't know whether
segment a B is congruent to CD they
never told us that we don't know how far
apart these things are so we know that
Phi is equal to a so this this this
statement right over here is just
suspect and so actually I don't I don't
like that one so I'm going to go with
the first one which is it's a little you
know takes a little bit of visualization
to going on but if you took angle AOC
and you rotated it 180 degrees which
means take the corresponding rays or the
Rays that make it up and rotate it 180
degrees you get to angle B OD and the
angle between those rays or the measure
of the angles we're just talking about
shouldn't change so I feel really good
about this second choice